continuing.
[Silence]
Allah.
Come on.
two verse.
And
that weation
revelation
the second chapter
the third chapter
in that order. This is the first account
of
the mention
and MSI
and the story of MS and
now
if we take the verse on its own
that means something but if we are to
take these verses as the first mention
that Allah makes
to the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
of the story of MS and
this is the introduction of that. How is
Pharaoh introduced to us? How is Musam
introduced to us? That adds another
layer of meaning and adds to the context
of these verses. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says in these verses that which
translates to indeed and listen very
closely to the exact wording of the
verses the exact wording because the
wording is curious
it's curiously worded and I want to ask
you after you hear the wording
what part of it strikes you as curious
meaning it's unconventional in its
wording for a reason obviously.
He says, "Subhan,
indeed we have sent to you all speaking
to the people of Mecca or speaking to
the disbelievers of Quraysh or speaking
to all of mankind, anyone who hears
these verses. Indeed, we have sent to
you all a messenger
as a witness upon you,
just as we have sent to Pharaoh a
messenger.
And Pharaoh
disobeyed that messenger.
And so we then took him with a very
heavy and very terrible punishment.
Now what about that wording
strikes you as interesting?
He says indeed we have sent to you all a
messenger just as we have sent to
Pharaoh a messenger.
What of that sentence is not as
expected?
Anyone want to take a
take a a try?
You look you want to try. I want
you to try. I want you to succeed, too.
What? What is it?
[Arabic recitation]
So, we have here that Pharaoh is
mentioned, but the messenger isn't
mentioned.
So, Misam isn't mentioned.
He didn't say we have sent to you all
a m a messenger as we have sent to
Pharaoh Mus. He said a messenger
not what I was looking for but good try
next time in what what about you?
You were going to say the same thing. So
Pharaoh's mentioned but the messenger is
not. Anyone else? Yes.
You're close. Listen to the pronouns.
Listen to the lame the pronouns here.
Hey. Yes.
You hear this guy? Mashallah, we have
our own homegrown mues here. Look at
this intellectual.
,
fun fact about our homegrown
intellectual. He's an architect. An
architect or an engineer? An engineer
and a lawyer. God help us. So here we
have what is curious
is the pronouns here. We have sent to
you all a messenger
as we have sent to Pharaoh singular. The
first was was plural. We have sent to
you all plural a messenger as we have
sent to Pharaoh singular a messenger.
It's a very interesting wording because
you are expecting that the wording and
the pronouns match up because Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala here is telling us
that just this story was your story
is as well to unfold.
The story was that MS was sent to
Pharaoh and Pharaoh disobeyed. So we
punished him and we have sent to you all
a messenger. You expect that the wording
would be we have sent to you all a
messenger plural as we sent to the
people of Pharaoh a messenger plural
matching with plural right or
we have sent to each of you a messenger
as we sent to Pharaoh a messenger
singular and singular that's what you
expect but here we have
Why is that? Why is it worded that way?
The
word pharaoh
in the Arabic language
is
an arabized
word.
What does arabized mean? Arabized means
that
you have a meaning, an idea, a product,
a title that is not
domestic, it is it is foreign to the
Arab language.
And so when that idea or when that
product is brought into the Arab
culture,
its name is brought in with it and they
give the name that is another language.
They give it Arab letters
in order to introduce that word. So for
instance, if we were to say
the names of the messengers, all the
names of the messengers are names which
are
they are all foreign names. They're not
Arab names. L
there's only four Arab names in the
Quran of messengers. Do we need do we
know those names? What are they
and Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam?
Those are the only four Arab names. The
rest are all what? Foreign names.
They're either Aramaic or whatever
language they've been brought over in.
Ibraim, for instance, it's not Arabic.
It's a foreign name.
Mika. These are all foreign names. But
when they are brought into the Arabic
language, they are given Arab
letters. Arabic letters. This process is
called Arabizing.
In Arabic, it's called
and
for
[Silence]
and so pharaoh
is not an Arabic word originally.
It is the title of anyone who
rules over the Egyptians.
[Silence]
So for instance, the name
is not Arabic is not a a name. It's a
title. It's a title for whoever rules
over the Romans.
It's kind it's Khalifa for instance
in other languages. Kisar
is the title for the king of who or the
emperor, the one who presides or rules
over the Persians. And Nashi
is a title of those who rule over the
Ethiopians. Tubar is a title for those
who rule over Yemen
and so forth. So Pharaoh
is originally a title
of whoever presides over the Egyptians.
When it was brought into the Arabic
language, it carried a meaning with it.
That meaning is that the Arabs actually
used this title and made verbs out of
it.
for
[Silence]
men
And so the word Pharaoh now means in the
Arabic language someone who is very
arrogant,
someone who is very controlling, a
tyrannical force,
a force of arrogance and rejection and
tyranny
and someone who plots in evil. They will
use this word in Arabic to describe such
a person.
And this is our first introduction of
Pharaoh in all of the Quran. This is the
first time our prophet sallallah.aii was
hearing of it.
And so Allah introduces him and
introduces Pharaoh in his story to the
people of Mecca in this way. Indeed, we
have sent to you all. All of you, all of
you, a messenger
just as we have sent to Pharaoh, a
messenger to Pharaoh. The connotations
of that name
is as we have sent to a man who was very
arrogant, a man who was very tyrannical,
a man who was very intelligent but
used his intelligence for the wrong
things.
And so how did that what was the outcome
of that? Pharaoh rejected. And so we
punished him. From this verse and verses
it, the scholars tell us
[Silence]
that every single person, every human
being
has in him of the spirit of Pharaoh.
Every human being has a part of him that
is the spirit of Pharaoh, the spirit of
arrogance, the spirit of wanting to be
tyrannical, wanting to control, wanting
to oppress,
desiring and straining to
overstep his bounds. All of the
descriptions that we have in the Quran,
every human being has a part of that in
him.
And every human being
has a part of the spirit of Musam in
him.
Misam who was sent to Pharaoh
to counteract that.
And what does the person end up becoming
of the people of paradise or the people
of the hellfire?
We can say it is safe to say that every
person of paradise
was able to win over his Pharaoh self.
And every person of hellfire
was
unable to win over his Pharaoh self.
And so every person has in him the
spirit of
the desire to do that. As a matter of
fact, the scholars tell us the only
difference between Fyon
and every other person
is that Fun had the ability
to do the things that he did. But most
people do not have the ability to do the
things that he did.
When you look at people, evil people in
the past
mentioned in the Quran, Pharaoh, a good
example, he was a man who murdered,
spilled blood. He was a tyrant. He was
oppressive.
He put people in prison camps. He
murdered children and babies.
A person would look at himself and say,
"No, no, no. I would never do that.
Pharaoh once started out as a man just
that. I would never do that. I'm a
good person.
But as the things presented themselves,
what did Pharaoh do? Slowly slowly he
slipped into
giving into those to that darkness
until he unleashed upon the people of Bi
is and his own people the most terrible
person that could have come out.
And for this reason, Allah tells us in
the Quran
that whoever murders one person, it's as
if he has murdered what?
Say it loud.
[Arabic recitation]
A person who kills another person, it's
as if he has killed all of mankind.
And a person who saves another person,
it's as if he has what? saved all of
mankind.
What's the difference? The difference is
the situation, the context. That's the
only difference. If a person murders
another person because that person is in
his way. What about if it was two
people? Would he do it? Three people?
That same context presents itself, but
instead of being two people, it's three.
How about 10? At what point do you draw
the line and say, "No, no, no, that's
too much murder. People did not draw the
line there. Once you have crossed that
threshold,
that person hypothetically is capable of
killing all of mankind
and vice versa. And so the difference
between us and Pharaoh, the the human
being and Pharaoh is that Pharaoh
was able. He had the capability
of doing whatever came to his mind,
whatever his shan whispered to him.
However,
many other people do not have those
capabilities. So it stays in check and
it stays balanced.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sent to us a
messenger
just he sent to Pharaoh a
messenger.
Pharaoh
rejected that messenger
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala took him
with punishment. Now notice the wording.
He didn't just say belied him or
disbelieved in the messenger. He said
disobeyed
the messenger. And that disobedience is
enough for disbelief because disbelief
is a type of disobedience which we will
get into tomorrow inshallah
subhanahuaala.
And
what it
Allah subhanahua